my good friend who is got his own
podcast now called beyond the x's and
o's where every podcaster found the
stories of the quarterback journey from
the mouths of the quarterbacks
themselves as hosted by great trent
dilfer back here on the show how are you
doing tren
doing good i think people like my pod
because i don't talk very much what do
you mean
it's not true that's not true people
like it when you talk what are you
talking about so
who are some of your guests you've had
on already trent on your pod aikman
favre
moon um warner
uh
and dilfer your own oh no there's a lot
more sorry i'm going brain dead i've
been game planning all morning uh
yesterday mark sanchez came on he was
hilarious
fantastic um
got ryan leaf coming on
um trying to hit john lynch came on his
his was one of the best steve young john
lynch came on because people forget he
was a quarterback i love cruz
quarterback
tells the story of bill walsh sitting
him down saying hey you're a good
quarterback but you could hall of fame
safety
and uh so just really cool stories from
those of the quarterbacks about their
high school years their college years
recruiting their nfl experience what
they're doing now
i love it well i don't know if i qualify
trent but i threw a pass in a demo
segment on game day morning that went
off of michael irvin's hand because he's
butterfingers despite being in the hall
of fame um so let's go i mean does that
qualify do i i'm the quarterback of my
shows that i host i don't know if that's
right that that could we've had that
conversation and we'll bring you home
oh man trent dilfer here uh on the rich
eisen show so um amidst your game
planning uh of the uh the team that you
coached there uh in tennessee lipscomb
academy correct did i get that one right
yeah okay great great good memory so um
yeah i have no notes on the quarterback
of this show so um
so what do you think
matt neggie's thinking right now with
justin fields what's going through his
mind on this subject matter
[Applause]
i think the reason they like dalton so
much was because and they were going to
stick with them was because he could
process quickly he could handle all the
offense he can get them in good plays
out of bad plays there's so much of the
quarterback position nfl right now that
just doesn't get
talked about and a lot of that is just
mitigating damage
um you're trying to prevent negative
plays
uh they felt great about that justin's
probably great in the film room he's
probably great on the board but there's
this huge transition from the white
board to the white lines in the nfl
i think it's the most difficult part of
the transition is you can get it in the
room you can see it you can watch it on
tape you can pro you can comprehend it
you can draw it up you can answer your
quiz questions and you get out there
between the white lines
and it looks different it feels
different it happens faster everybody
talks about the games faster well a lot
of it's faster with information it's not
just the speed of the players that that
that comment's been dumbed down over the
years uh every analyst says hey the
game's faster well no kidding
it but it's not just the athletes
it's the processing of information
happens so much faster and that's what
happens
to a lot of these young guys and now
he's sitting there going golly
you know dalton wasn't doing a great in
his banged up fields i thought at least
we'll create some time and space with us
with his athleticism and that didn't
happen
i'm people are now starting to call me
adam gase
i gotta put some points on the board so
i gotta figure out the guy that can get
us out there and be explosive and put
points on the board and at the same time
not cause us negative plays he's in a
tough spot right now well i mean the
name of this show is the rich eisen show
and not the x's and o's uh podcasts like
yours so i'm not an access no guy but i
i do have a set of eyes uh the number of
times that they would just drop fields
back and just say okay clowny and and
and garrett meet in the middle like it i
didn't see the scheme very much to get
him out on the edge or or create some
sort of of action with him and his
terrific running back in montgomery that
who's got the ball like there was i
didn't see any of that unless the browns
dictated so much that that couldn't be
run what are your things
they've gone ultra spread and that was
maggie's mo in kansas city you know was
he added that spread flavor to andy
reed's west coast offense
and they've gotten ultra spread and
there are some incredible things about
the spread i mean it is from a football
dork like myself studying football
coaching there's some really great
elements and and you see them show up
throughout the nfl now and you couldn't
say that six seven years ago
but you they're not your fastball they
can't be your 96 mile per hour heater
because you lose physicality you lose
deception you lose change you don't
change the launch point enough uh man
coverage and blitzes destroy it or you
just rush three and drop eight which is
the opposite now you flood zones up
um
it has to be a supplement to a baseline
offense
and i
the little i've seen of the bears i
watched this week's i want to see fields
but even last year watching a lot of
them
uh
he's gone away from that he's gone away
from the nuts and bolts of having a a
standard offense which is you know a
physical run game it can be two back it
could be one bad it can be a lot of
different things it's gotta be a
physical run game an inline tight end
that's dominant
action pass both from the pocket half
rolls and full roll outs like you have
to change the launch point quick game
screen game like all these things that
are staples in the best offense nfl what
did you see the cowboys last night you
saw a ton of offense you saw all kinds
of different schemes one of the best
things keller moore does is yeah he
likes to throw it a little bit too much
but he does it a bunch of different ways
so that's back prescott's not always in
the same place so the defensive line
can't hunt to the same area every play i
think what you're seeing is a guy that's
gone ultra spread and you become
predictable when you go spread
so what is the answer in terms of
fields you know obviously the jets and
the jaguars are going to keep throwing
their guys out there but what is the
answer with fields like where you said
the processing from the grease board in
the film room to
real time
uh athletes coming at you in a real game
is difficult to grasp i mean can can you
grasp it better watching or you grasp it
better practicing with the ones all week
and taking your lumps on a sunday
i've been torn i was always the one that
said let him watch and now i've kind of
morphed into let him play yeah and
there's a big f
the if is if you as a staff offensive
staff
feel like you can out coach the other
side of the ball
if you feel like you can create enough
cheese on sundays and what the cheese is
is the free stuff
every when you watch these great
offensive offenses play uh whoever they
are you're gonna see 10 to 15 and all of
us quarterbacks talk about this all the
time you see about 10 to 15 freebies
just absolute cheddar out there like
it's six six-yard hitch it's a bootleg
throw the ball in the flat it's a
mystery it's a shovel pass it's some
type of creative offense where you just
get an easy play
if you can create easy plays let them
play and build their confidence and
start building the offense around their
strengths and their weaknesses
uh if you don't feel like you can do
that and you're a system coordinator
you're a system staff hey we run a
system and you can't run the system you
can't play and don't play them because
it's going to take them a while to learn
the system that's where the hardest part
is from the board to the lines is you're
trying to process this system and all
the rules in this system and then you go
out there on sundays you're like whoa
this isn't the way we talked about it
what rule is that what's my read here or
they didn't play the defense we said
they're going to read what's my
rule and adjustment on that this blitz
is coming here who do i bring over here
to protect it
it's too much
but these young guys have had success if
you go back and you study the tape it is
multiple freebies a game we give them
freebies a game and now they get their
confidence up and now you start falling
into something offensively like hey with
this guy we can do this we can do that
we can create deception here and we can
get a free play here and there and all
of a sudden you're rolling
trent till for beyond the x's and o's
podcast you should get it we're all
podcasts required head coach at lipscomb
academy in
tennessee joining me here on the rich
eisen show what's going through mack
jones's mind as tom brady's coming home
um angry what do you think's going on in
that young man's lid
i think he's excited listen he's playing
well he is playing really well his eyes
are you talking about a guy that's
jumped in taken from the grease board to
the white lines he is
he's dialed in he throws a couple picks
the other day once he's getting hit the
ball just flutters not his fault the
second one goes off your receiver's
hands the third one's with eight seconds
left in the game trying to put some
needless points on the board so it's not
he's being careless with the football uh
he's playing the position fast on time
um i think he's excited now
they're playing a ticked off tom brady
who's coming to foxborough and he's
gotta anticipate the assassins showing
up
but i think from his side
if he's focused on controlling what he's
can control he's 30-51 the other day
under some tough situations trailing the
whole time against a good defense
uh the wind's blown he's knifing it
through the wind he's making plays with
his feet he made some off platform plays
like his confidence is only growing
and i think you know any young guy
listen to play quarterback you better be
a legend in your own mind so i i mean
brett favre was ten times the player i i
was but when i'd go up to lambo to play
him i wanted to show up for a farm like
in my mind i was gonna be the star of
the game and i was gonna beat that far
and i would tell him that before the
game and we'd joke about it i think mack
jones is a great competitor
he's gonna have that mentality like come
on tom bring your best i'm gonna play
better than you so if mac jones took
your approach the way you did to favor
and lambo would he go up to brady and
say i'm gonna beat you today like you
look no it's more of a joking thing but
it'd also be owen 10 and lambo
i'm not saying it's a good strategy i'm
just saying you have to have that
mentality it is hard playing quarterback
the nfl is flipping hard and you better
be a legend in your own mind you better
have supreme confidence you better be
able to bounce back you better not go in
the tank and i i think i think matt
jones right now and his mind is saying
i'm going to be one of the best players
in the league just give me time a few
minutes more left with trent tilford
here on on the rich eisen show you were
one of the first to come on this show
and talk about tua you saw him in the
elite 11 year you talked about how you
saw him make the throw in elite 11 play
that he made uh in the national
championship game uh when he has
allegedly had miami at hello and now
he's miami's guy and they were kicking
the tires reportedly on deshaun watson
before the season he's now hurt you saw
what brisette did against vegas and
you're already hearing again that tour's
done in miami where you you people in
miami say that i hear it as well that
he's just a guy in the nfl that's what
he's proven to be i give you the floor
on where you think tua stands uh now a
year plus into his career in miami on
iowa well i'm gonna i'm an apologist for
two uh i but i also i i get
i just don't know who's saying this
because people i'm talking to
rave about a how he handled off season
raved about his training camp uh played
well early before he got hurt
uh he is hurt i mean he has bad ribs he
took an absolute slobber knocker shot
on his ribs
um
i think he had let the guy play a little
bit i'm not going to write off zach
wilson after this year he's going to
play crappy the whole year and it's not
going to get much better
and he can't write these guys they're
supremely talented off that are putting
in the work and doing the right things
and and just don't have the support
um
i i still think it was a supreme talent
i i think giving them the right people
around him which they're getting there
in miami the right play caller which
they finally have and charlie fry one of
these
hugely bright stars in the nfl as a
young play caller um you start giving
him these tools and he's gonna be wildly
successful i i i feel bad for him and i
don't like when people are jumping off
the bandwagon of talented players so
quickly well it seems like it's also the
dolphins too why would they be kicking
the tires on somebody with more baggage
than los angeles international and
desean watson just a couple weeks before
the season
yeah i don't know that answer i i know a
lot of teams have kicked the tires onto
sean watson um nothing's happened and
maybe there's a reason why nothing's
happened um
if he does end up going somewhere else i
would still believe in two of he's got
to have the same things every
quarterback needs when when they're
growing in the position they need
support from the play caller and the
people around him and a good defense and
a great organization and
structure and all those things that all
these quarterbacks are going to be in
the hall of fame one day half but is
that how you would build around two of
the track stars at wide receiver uh
gesicki a tight end like the is is this
i like what they've done i like what
miami's done uh in the draft i liked i
like i said i think their young play
caller charlie frye is
your next sean mcvay slash matt lefore
you know these rock star young guys he's
as good as there is in the business okay
um
i think he needs a chance to play
now
your best ability in the nfl is
availability and if you stay hurt
they're gonna move on and that at that
point you can't be an apologist for a
player because
he's not on the field he needs to be on
the field he needs to be playing he's be
taking his lumps he needs to be
making gains he needs to be doing all
the things that these other guys are
doing i daniel jones real quick i think
danielle jones would be a really good
player i know it's not going well in new
york but he's going to go back and be
grateful for these days when they do
turn it around because he's learning so
much how to manage and play the position
and be a celebrity and be a starting
quarterback and be the quarterback uh
and you have to play every week to learn
how to be a quarterback yeah or you
could turn into sam darnold which is get
your exits visas from the
metlife stadium and then wind up 3-0 in
the new spot you know the second spot
for a lot of these young guys is going
to be their spot it's just that's just
the reality of where we're going um
because they draft them so early they're
young they can't support them then they
give up on them but then the next team
sees the diamond in the rough and they
are talented enough they get them a
little bit cheaper and now you have the
sam darnold experience well i know the
steelers are hoping that's the spot for
dwayne haskins maybe you know like that
that that's probably what they're
thinking right now yep deep down hey
trent thanks for the time really
appreciate it let's do this more often
look for my uh my text and call congrats
on the pod and again like if you need a
guy who can give you a couple snaps in a
demo and refer to himself as a
quarterback because if he's a television
host i'm talking about myself you just
let me know let's go let's talk about
yourself all you want buddy okay love
you love you and miss you right back at
you that's trent dill for everybody
check out his podcast beyond the x's and
o's some great conversations right there
aikman and farvan lynch that's probably
good bill walsh uh how about that uh hey
you know you're not you're okay
quarterback but you could be a hall of
fame safety guess what he is now
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here